que pretende el régimen de pyongyang con
esta escalada cambia en algo el panorama
de que el misil haya sobrevolado Japón
gracias Ángela sin duda es súper
importante establecer que se trataría de
una medida por parte de el gobierno de
pyong medida desesperada en el sentido
que se siente amenazado sobre todo con
la visita la semana anterior de Harris
en la zona de desmilitarización con todo
este tema de ejercicios militares
también entre Corea del Sur Estados
Unidos y Japón y no se veía un misil que
pasara por este territorio desde el 15
de septiembre de 2017 que también era un
momento bastante álgido porque se estaba
presionando para que se dieran nuevas
negociaciones entre el gobierno en ese
momento de Donald Trump y Kim jong-un
esto también recuerda una medida
bastante interesante en el contexto
Claro que obviamente también el régimen
de quien yo no ha podido enriquecer
mucho más su tema de potenciales misiles
sin embargo hasta el momento se ve más
como una provocación que como una
posibilidad de nuevos misiles en el
corto plazo
bueno y ahora le pregunto preocupa este
tipo de prácticas después de que Corea
del Norte declarara Irreversible su
política nuclear y que promulgara una
ley que permite ataques preventivos
sin duda y hay que recordar que Japón
también en el escenario juega un papel
supremamente relevante Pese a que no
tenga ejército como tal por una
prohibición en su Artículo número noveno
de la Constitución es uno de los 10
países también que mayor invierte en el
ámbito militar es una atención nueva que
se encuentra en la región y esto viene
unido a esas potenciales nuevas
sociedades que se dan en este momento en
Asia
finalmente Cuál sería la reacción de la
comunidad internacional porque bueno
está claro que las sanciones no
funcionan al día de hoy Corea del Sur
habló por ejemplo de consecuencias Pero
no especificó cuales
claro veíamos en el periodos anteriores
en años anteriores una posibilidad
no de integración pero sí de bajarle la
atención entre Corea del Sur y Corea del
Norte la comunidad internacional vemos
Tiene bastantes ocupaciones hoy por hoy
pero evidentemente condena totalmente
estos sucesos Y sí preocupa muchísimo
con los potenciales otros socios que
tienen este momento Corea del Norte Como
Irán o llámese Rusia también que está
jugando muy al favor de este último